instance because if he done a six
siberia what's about the only one he can
do without with with the surprising me
so sixth buoy no sorry just the ski part
so the ski part
all right
so i'm safe
so
so you just need to just a few times you
know with with each
and why i've put you in threes is
because
each person attacks different each
person's body weight is different you're
going to have to
over
the period today you're gonna have to
calculate what you're dealing with
and just being a robot of doing the same
thing every time i oh i'm okay here look
i'm miles away
you know he might extend the next person
might extend more extend more you know
that means that
all right so
for the seniors
you should be able to sort of work that
out that you don't need to
do that but i i think for everybody if
you just for now just do that
they cut
your hand comes up
in reality your hand wouldn't come up
but what we're doing here is we're
getting a timing
we're getting that we're getting the
timing going
it's as if
his ken
and my finger
has a piece of string tied to it
okay
it comes from the partner practice
yeah
all right just just do that so this
person will cut
reasonably slow at first the higher the
rank faster that you the cat should be
hey
[Music]
hi
okay
so
the higher the rank the the faster you
should be cutting
okay so i just want to show you here
we've got two high-level
people
they should be really cutting like fast
at their level
but what the problem is and
around this way no
that's it
this way
what the problem is
okay so i just want to explain what the
problem is look
since he used
when they asked scentsy how do you teach
he said i just teach
yeah but how do you teach beginners he
said i just teach
in other words you know he didn't make
any it's up to you to grab what you
think's important
if i start saying
you know you lean this way for the
beginners and more up like you know it's
it's we're gonna build all day talking
really about things that aren't
important
but this is what the problem is all
right and we all do it
i'm in line
i'm in line with my attacker
hey i come here and then what you done
was this
am i in line with the attacker no now
i've gone smaller and i've actually gone
off the line
without knowing it
i've already gone in self-defense mode
but what about the guy now starts
actually cutting where he's twigged that
i've gone
that then starts bouncing me out because
i wasn't ready for him to come over a
few centimeters
so the pus
one thing about scentsy was
he was a stickler for being precise and
if you weren't precise exactly every
time he'd shout and shout at you so if
you're on the line
hey
and not now
it's no good
so if you start on the line
hey
oh no good sorry that's right my fault
i got your hand and i shouldn't have
done um
so
be precise know where you are it's it
must he used to say it's not like
it's not like you're not a machine you
know each time
[Applause]
hey
you've got to center yourself each time
if he starts pumping away and just
attacking
it just slow him up a little bit
you know it's your aikido it's your
advancement that's important
this one tacks the head
this one goes underneath now
underneath
so
what i like about this one is
if we're in a car
and i decide to change gears it might be
a different speed
than perhaps somebody else driving the
car so i might like to change
gear every 3000 revs
and you might like to change it two and
a half thousand webs
so what i have to do is first i
i marry his timing let's do it real slow
at this slow up and down
here i'm up same speed
then i have to quickly accelerate
because i need to be then ahead of him
if i'm here and then
if i can't get there now
get in there
by the time he reaches the bottom
so it's no good going
i can't do the technique i want to show
you i can do what i done and lost the
thing what i can do is a coat of gosh
okay
but the one we're going to do
is very slowly
up now i have to accelerate so i'm there
i'll talk about this more in a minute
this point in a minute
so i have to accelerate
from the top to the bottom
and you punch
from here
okay on a glass mask
the detail we're going to come in closer
with the camera for the detail
what happens is at the bottom of the
strike
your hands in the middle here but what
happens is when you push your hand
sometimes pops through
the hole
here
hit pop you go like that and it
so you
that's all you get
so
i'm going to give you it's nice and
there are secrets in aikido even if they
pretend there are as i come in
as i come in
here as this turns
it allows me to
i'm actually going to now go over to
richard there
with my wrist
so it locks against his wrist
and that's
why he's got a choice whether he just
steps or not
all right so as long as you locked him
here
everybody's there the lock
you've locked them
if you don't lock them
[Music]
you don't lock them
you know you push like that and
it can slip off or
so this is no good
because i've turned i've come around
here
it does that
okay
i'll turn this way
because i've turned
here
it's turned him that way
all right
so that's uh that's a little thing that
i hadn't realized you know we do it
sometimes as teachers and we don't
realize we're not actually telling
anybody about what we're doing because
we don't know we're doing it ourself
but it's all to do with the turn so
the turn
is here
here as long as it's this side
okay as long as it's that side and take
a little
stamp
sorafuni
chorophony
all right
it's you can't see what's coming out of
a person but we all have to work on the
building of it i don't want to go
well the problem is it's timing
yeah it's timing
right
what's happened is he's he's turned and
he's wasted the last quarter of his body
movement
the fingers tips need to go in earlier
before he turns
right there that's yes all right
look catchy dory i said at the beginning
thank you i said at the beginning it's
it's quite boring because if we don't
know what we're doing
we sort of stand you know all day
thinking why isn't it working let me do
it slowly
i enter i'm with his ken
as my body turns my arm becomes we'll
say one
so when i get to here he's already there
and then i just step
if you if you get to here at the bottom
you've got nothing to turn any physical
strength now in your hand this is too
late i need to go back here
start putting it on there
right so i put it on earlier but you
can't put it until you're there but it's
the it's the feeding in
of that and then
and then since he you know would punch
like this
to some of you experienced ones it'll
make more sense now
roku
so i'm going to show you broken down
slowly so
i come in here
i start to turn i take the top hand
and i roll it round and then i go
against his elbow be careful because it
hurts
from what i remember it hurts anyhow
okay nice ken
come on
okay this is roku now but it's just the
start is the same
the finish is the extra hand
[Music]
if you if you start resisting only on
these if you start resisting you're
going to go home with injuries
all right so there's it's time for being
strong and there's time for trying to
blend you know we both learn something
this
is called roku
now a lot of you are going back here
and then you're having to put something
on
now roku it means just means the 6.2
gokyo is normally knife taking
we know
ikkyo nikkiyosenko yonkyo but we rarely
talk about gokyo and roku but raku is
about the worst one you want somebody
powerful to do on you because it'll
either snap the elbow or really hurt the
elbow
so that's why i'm trying to be kind and
saying go easy but where you turn
changes on roku
and it changes depending on what the
how the person is coming so if the
person is coming straight at you
by going round the back
you know he can perhaps resist me and
come back up
so in this case because he's coming
forward we need to go
forward
here i need to
punch him forward
all right and if he comes up
i'm not doing anything that's him who's
trying to get out look i'm just staying
here
i am adding a little bit more nail down
on the wrist
what you can't see
no
but
all right so by some of you are sweeping
that's all i'm saying
now
if it was a joe ski
you really want to go what i call
upstream with him you want to go sort of
up that way first and then
put the brakes on
so a lot of you are just
going round i'm wondering now that's why
he's not got it on
i should have been about there
right so there's a place
where it can go on there's a place where
it can't go on
okay
he likes the training so it's good
all right so please if it doesn't feel
right you know if he doesn't feel i was
sort of looking at raj early and i
thought
he's there but he's not he's sort of
thinking
ain't quite right but you don't know
where to step
so it's the cutting the cake always
sometimes it's right round here
right around here and then here
another time it might be as they come
lead them up
and here
so there's no place i can tell you where
the feet should be
you should feel that as a as an aikidoka
right if it doesn't feel right where
you've done it this time
try a new place next time
because we're all individuals and we all
act differently okay
[Music]
not saying there isn't anybody
um
you can't really do a rocker unless it's
from a ski either ski with a joe or you
know
ski with a ken it needs to be going
forward
okay
so
if i done rock who has a lot of you
seniors or know it
i'd take underneath
but
but look i can't trap his hand now
so i can't track his hand and why would
he turn why would he turn that
if he now does the ski
ski
that's so so raku can be done from skis
because they're turning
their hand usually
so i just
i was thinking about this and i thought
well a lot of people don't get that but
if they start to learn the angle they
can actually see how
you know you can start to
mold things
so what is this
what is this technique
nicki oh
so
so you're starting to lock on okay the
next one that most of you should know is
coated guys
since he was always very accurate about
this thumb must be on this
knuckle here
when we hold the ken or joe we hold it
always with these two fingers
okay the rest of the fingers are there
but there's there shouldn't be any real
power there
and when the and because we take
taijitsu from the weapons
here's a good example of i can get two
fingers in here
but i can't get the whole hand in
so between the thumb and the two fingers
you've got the technique
so you're here
you can
tell me if you want you know you can add
this but today i'm more interested in
getting to here
step
this way
but as you step this way don't bring
this around this hip
but
push it to him
there's your tummy
you can't do normal guys you're gonna
need a new offend or something
so here
for the seniors what i'd like for the
seniors is when i do it
down here inside my stomach
i feel this turn
when i go like that i feel this turn
that adds mass
so i'm creating mass
so
but when do you start learning about
this yellow belt orange belt you learn
it when your time is to absorb it
one
two
i've got him there
look
take this out
there's the coat of gosh
push it towards him
you seniors i want you now to connect
this
make the circle
inside your body
step across like normal gosh now when
this back leg spins
you take the ken
and you
finish the cut
okay
and you should
so i'm i'm looking at you seniors and
saying if this isn't happening
then you you need to work on it don't
worry about him tapping
okay come on
so let's try don't worry
oh hopefully uh
those of you will remember
pieces danny
okay this is a cola geesh again but this
time
this hammy
you go behind him
turn
take
oh
okay please try and get this if you've
got enough space
oh not supposed to get aggressive over
here
there we go
all right so let's look slowly i'm on
this had me if i go oh
i just made it
then you've got to start you're in your
own you're in your own way
so
it may be more for the seniors it may
not
you've got to know
just the distance of his cat
if you can just see him here
you should be able to look
don't work out where should my face what
should my feet be doing your feet need
to just do that really
just lift them up and down and don't try
and move them about too much that
usually puts you where you need to be
that puts you there and then you know
the rest
okay
student or whatever we should always be
precise you know if the class starts on
time you should be there early you know
it's it's all about making a human being
and tweaking them to become a martial
artist you know i was watching a seventh
dan yesterday do joe dory and he's
standing like this you know he's
standing square
it's because he's a seventh down he's
arrived you don't mean he's made it
it's still wrong
you know if i essentially said this is
the aikido posture that's the ico
posture yeah but i'm seven down now and
i made it you know so i was watching
this person who's very well respected
and um
i thought you're insulting the art
because you're not sharp anymore you
know just because we're getting old you
don't you shouldn't use lose sharpness
we're going to have a 10 minute teal
coffee break if you whatever you said
it's nigel
that's what you're getting got your name
on the tea or the coffee but
um so we'll have a 10 minute break
i i was saying to um the fifth dance
about
subash
video ken ken
i was saying to the fifth dance look
there's different levels of learning
when your q grade or even first second
down you've got to watch really close
you've got to concentrate really close
you've got to sort of watch and work out
when he stops where his hands are you've
got to work at everything where are you
turn turn turn
oh i'm having to reach now
i need to be a bit closer oh i'm too
close
the detail that's why i'm still doing it
i could after all these years because it
still fascinates me it's the detail
where if you go on the right path i
think the right path
as soon as he put his ken out there and
before that i was plugged into him
when i say plugged into him i could feel
his energy i can feel him moving about
he's moving me so i might as an
individual when he cuts take a step and
think right but then fine when i turn
i'm miles away from getting it and i'm
having to reach up there now i'm in the
way so i've got to get out the way
so it all goes wrong
so
until you're ready
you've got to watch look do everything
work things out work out where you are
as you get better
you want to do that but oh he stopped me
i wanted to sort of do this deeper thing
but i felt his his body energy his aura
whatever you want to call it it stopped
me
and i go oh i gotta stop there
so i'm the puppet of the attacker
because how can two people become one if
i'm expecting him to become one with me
he's the attacker so i've got to
actually blend with him
so
it's easy look
hands there step there that's right
there
how do you find that you find it by
very slowly going
oh yeah i felt him stop me i know where
he is so i don't have to worry about it
i don't have to make any adjustments i
just turn oh yeah look there's his hand
so a lot of it is trusting
in what you never use
your subconscious your internal
your internal things the things that you
never rely on you rely on
this ego consciousness
that actually
won't ever make you advance it'll just
keep you as a technical practitioner
all right